Newsradio 11:10 KFAB it's the crisps
maker radio program alright so everybody
is for some reason we're all captivated
over the murder of a Saudi national US
resident in Turkey wrote for the
Washington Post and always looking for
new perspective joining us on the show
right now David Pakman David Pakman is a
very busy man a commentator college
instructor internet personality David
thank you very much for clawing your way
out of your schedule to join us here on
the Chris Baker radio show oh good well
we're very excited to to be up there um
David I'm very confused as to why this
story in Turkey seems to I don't know
people seem to want to blame President
Donald Trump about this how do you see
this I haven't seen anyone blame Trump
for the killing who who's done that I
just haven't seen that it just seems it
always comes back any time I see any
anyone talking about this on television
it's always well the presidents got to
do this and what's the president gonna
do about that and I'm just curious as to
how did it become our responsibility
here well I don't think so just to be
clear you said your first assertion was
you see people blaming the president and
you said people are asking about how
he's going to react which of course are
two different things I haven't heard
anybody blame him for the killing yeah I
think the reason why people like would
be interested in seeing how Donald Trump
would respond would be a couple reasons
I mean number one well this was not a US
citizen it was someone living in the
United States who also was a was a
journalist working in the United States
so it's important to make sure that
we're defending sort of the institution
of the Free Press and this is not a
president we particularly friendly to
that institution so I think it would be
reasonable just K how he would respond
on that but but for me it's not really
about Trump specifically like whoever if
you look back
many recent presidents they've all been
very cozy with this totally brutal
authoritarian theocracy that is Saudi
Arabia and I've been critical of all of
those presidents
it just happens to be that Trump is the
one now who continues to be cozy with
this brutal dictatorship and it's a
relationship that that is a disaster
quite frankly so I think that that's
what a lot of being questions are coming
from it's not about Trump specifically
what what do you what would you like to
see him do and this is really the
question and that's why I'm happy to
have you on the show today yes that I've
asked people what do you want him to do
and I never get it what do people want
him to do I mean first of all Turkey
doesn't have a Free Press
Saudi Arabia doesn't have a free press
the United States of America has a free
press but when you look around the world
one of the countries really have the
press freedom that we have here in the
United States certainly I mean I think
mostly you would look to a majority of
Europe significant part of South America
for sure but I think the question you
ask is a good one which is what should
he do now right and the reason that it's
so difficult is if you said what should
happen in general with a relationship
with Saudi Arabia it's one that should
not be cozy right we should not be in
cahoots with an authoritarian theocracy
the way we are we now are in the
situation where we do huge arms sales
with them so there are American jobs
that depend on keeping things friendly
with Saudi Arabia we have a shared
interest in stability in the oil market
because we've not gotten off of fossil
fuels and they may have us over a barrel
literally and figuratively it's like
over a barrel of oil so that's the
problem it's not so much what it is that
he should do now I said its hands are
very tied now because of all of the
relationships that have been built with
Saudi Arabia over the decade well see I
don't know if there's any reason to be
critical of him because I mean one of
the things that that needs to be pointed
out here is that yes the United States
of America as all countries we have
dealings with dictatorships and scummy
people all over the world
makes me think back to the words of
Henry Kissinger years ago who said there
are no allies there are interest and
right now Saudi Arabia aids us in in our
fight against Iran which you know
they're not exactly the sweetest people
on the planet either gunning down their
own people in the streets so we do have
interest with them and it helps us
combat Isis has helps us combat other
Islamic jihadi groups historically does
it tend to work out for when we pick
which extremists to support against
other extremists like I get what you're
saying right now and I think what you're
saying it is in life as much of the sort
of general reporting about that
relationship but historically usually
picking which extremists to support has
exploded in our faces
I think it goes back to allies versus
interest and I would agree with you I
think you know from a personal level I
don't like the Saudi regime I don't like
any of these third-world bug-eaters
frankly I don't like it the fact that
they chop people's heads off in public
they don't let women drive their human
rights records is horrid I'd love to see
that change but also I'd like to point
out that recently the United States is
surpassing Saudi Arabia on oil exports
and we could probably do much better to
be less dependent on them if we weren't
constantly being her reined in to moving
away from fossil fuels which would be
fantastic but I don't know what people
want us to move to and I don't know
anyone who would not be happy to move to
something that would be a lateral move
economically in other words moving to so
other source that doesn't cost much more
well the reason why other sources cost
more right now is because we subsidize
oils but I don't know what your economic
views are but if you subscribe to the
idea of the free market then we should
not be subsidizing the fossil fuels
which are really bad for the environment
so you don't even necessarily have to
take the approach of subsidizing
renewables but but at least let's make
let's make it an actual competition and
not subsidized by
fulfilled I don't think you know it's
fine to say you would love to get off of
fossil fuels theoretically but unless we
get rid of the subsidies that's that's
just a non-starter but your first thing
is everybody should say well let's not
give an advantage so let's not pick
winners and losers by subsidizing oil
well I love the fact that you know well
I would love but here's what I would
love I would love for the United States
to be able to deal with its own fuel
needs and instead of you know fossil
fuels or energy is a world commodity we
spend in my opinion and by the way I'm
no expert on energy but from what I know
thank you
from what I know ok living in energy
producing cities and knowing numerous
individuals in that industry is that
instead of dealing with this as a world
commodity we could eliminate about a lot
of our own problems if we worried about
domestically producing fossil fuels and
then hopefully moving on to something
that's not fossil fuels fossil fuels I
think where we disagree is how we got
there and how soon now when I was sent
this nice email saying hey you got to
have this guy David Pakman on David by
David Pakman with us here on the Chris
Baker radio show I would highly
recommend you google him he's a big
internet celebrity teaches in college
he's a very smart man and really no I
congratulate you because you've been
able to become a real player in
multi-platform
broadcasting and and I applaud that I
really and truly do good for you I'll
make it it says here that there's
denials of wrongdoing by Russia that
enabled Saudi Arabia what exactly what
what is that what you mean by that I'm
not exactly sure what you have in front
of you I mean I think the denial that I
you may want to talk to your press guy
[Laughter]
yeah because here's what it says it says
TV radio host David Pakman is available
for interviews he recently did a piece
on how Trump's denials of wrongdoing by
Russia enabled Saudi Arabia to pull off
this brazen attack oh I think that maybe
he meant by Saudi Arabia what would ease
the denial he's referring to
that just after getting off the phone
with the Saudi Crown Prince Donald Trump
floated this idea that could have been
anybody that did this to Jamal show he
could have been quote rogue killers and
when I see a president in in opposition
to everything that was known as the time
repeat something that a Saudi Arabian
Crown Prince tells and I get concerned
and then as we learned about the
financial interest Trump has in Saudi
Arabia that he has since denied having
after bragging about those financial
interests that's what concerns me about
Trump specifically mm-hmm well we do
have a thing in America I know said the
Saudis don't participate in this but we
do have a thing called due process and
don't you think it would be I don't know
a little haphazard to start throwing
allegations around before you know the
whole story and don't get me wrong I
realize the Saudis are a bunch of
dirtbags talking about a criminal case
in the United States this is totally out
we're just talking about Trump's opinion
and it seems like you fell hook line and
sinker for a Saudi Crown Prince saying
we don't know who it could have could
have been anybody well could it have
been anybody inside the Saudi embassy in
Istanbul it couldn't really be anybody
and yeah it's also something that you
would say when you're just kind of
waiting for information and you're being
asked what are you gonna do what do you
think about this what are you gonna do
who did this don't you know who did this
I mean it's it's all I know I look at
this from a diplomatic perspective and I
don't know if it's a good idea to start
just throwing bombs out there well they
did this and we know it and we're gonna
prove it that kind of thing because I
don't think that does is any favors in
the long game because we did it without
having to say that there were low
killers right you could just say we're
first figuring out what's going on and I
think that that's a pretty reasonable
expectation of a president but have you
ever seen him use so few words no
all right David Pakman thank you so much
and for everyone's information I look up
David internet personality broadcaster
college instructor I mean this guy is a
very busy man and David we really
appreciate your time today thanks for
joining us on the show well thank you
for having me I appreciate it